things are heating up between pete
davidson and kim kardashian and now a
source tells et they are officially
dating and having a great time together
yes our source says quote pete and kim
are 100 dating and are very into each
other they are pretty much inseparable
and very affectionate when they're
together the source adds that the two
are super supportive of each other's
projects and are really taking an
interest in what the other is passionate
about exhibit a pete rocking the latest
holiday pajamas from the reality star's
shapewear and clothing line skims during
his b day bash earlier this week
alongside kim and her mom kris jenner
was the cutest thing the source adds
quote pete has been in a great mood
since him and kim got together and he is
very calm chill and easy to get along
with i love that as for kim a second
source tells et pete is a romantic who
goes out of his way to make kim feel
special case in point well earlier this
month kim's security guard was
photographed in new york city outside of
her hotel delivering a large bouquet of
red roses many assuming they were a gift
from pete a source says quote kim thinks
pete is hysterical and he's constantly
making her laugh but they have also been
connecting on a deeper level they're
enjoying getting to know each other
better and having a lot of fun it's
really lit and fun and crazy earlier
this week the pair was spotted smiling
and holding hands in palm springs
california where the rumored couple was
celebrating pete's 28th birthday at the
end of the day life is about being happy
but this isn't the first time kim and
pete have been photographed with some
pda they first sparked dating rumors
back in october when this pic of them
holding hands on a roller coaster at not
scary farm went viral after she appeared
alongside the actor on saturday night
live i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
[Music]
since then the two have been spotted on
several dinner dates including one at
pete's favorite restaurant in his
hometown of staten island the comedian
who was previously engaged to ariana
grande is the first man kim has been
romantically linked to since filing for
divorce from kanye west back in february
a source previously told et quote kim
has been protective of kanye and his
feelings she has been trying to keep her
hangouts with pete low key because she
doesn't know how he will react so until
kim and pete officially confirm keat is
a thing we'll just be here watching this
skit on repeat i'm just a little
concerned that
physically uh
i can't handle you
if we go all the way
you might like break me